[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs toutes
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
nous parlerons de trappes il y en aura
pour tous les goûts avec samedi une
soirée celtique à la merise est un
spectacle d'impro de déclic théâtre nous
recevront en plateau nous reignac in
with de la compagnie pour nous présenter
l'événement et le mondial de l'impro à
venir voisins le bretonneux réuni ses
lauréats dans une exposition jusqu'au 2
avril les spectateurs sont invités à
découvrir les artistes qui ont marqué
les deux dernière biennale de peinture
et de sculpture de la ville et mélanie
poquet nous a préparé un programme pour
occuper les plus jeunes tout le week end
natation handball ou petit chaperon
rouge plus de détails à suivre
mais on commence par un événement à ne
pas manquer samedi aux fermes de gally
c'est la fête des abeilles ces
pollinisateurs sont en danger 30% des
colonies d'abeilles disparaissent chaque
année
trois raisons à cela les pesticides les
maladies mais aussi le manque
d'alimentation cette journée ludique est
donc consacré aux plantes mellifères
source de nourriture de 10h à 18h des
animations sont prévues pour
sensibiliser le public et comprendre le
monde des abeilles
bruno gansel responsable communication
de la ferme nous en dit plus les plantes
mellifères ce sont des plantes qui vont
produire du nectar ou du pollen qui sont
deux des éléments que recherchent les
abeilles tout au long de l'année
on sait que des abeilles enfin
principalement
en été et à l'automne donc on va voir
également des ateliers permettant aux
gens de composer leurs jardinières de
plantes mellifères qui vont fleurir à ce
moment là on arrive à y avoir des
projections de films également sur les
pollinisateurs et les abeilles ambiance
celtique à la merise de trappes le
cercle c'est abel organise son fils noé
pour la 22e année au programme musique
bretonne et danses traditionnelles le
bagad de saint quentin en yvelines le
potier carte est et le golf le pardon le
goff et d'autres artistes animeront la
soirée de samedi dès 20 heures
l'occasion de revivre une vraie fête de
nuit à la bretonne un événement qui a
toujours autant de succès selon
l'association 16 av l on écoute un mot
de son vice président la musique
protégée se nourrir d autres musiques et
d'ailleurs le groupe leader qu'il sera
là demain à des sonorités de musique
orientale des pays de l'est comme c'est
une une musique qui se remet toujours en
cause qui innove donc il ya un nouveau
public à chaque fois qui vient
s'accrocher sur les sur des nouveautés
et on reste à trappes mais pour du
théâtre cette fois et pas n'importe
lequel d'improvisation la compagnie
déclic théâtre organise ce samedi dès
11h 30 des matches à l'école de musique
et de danse et pour nous en parler nous
relief qui nous lisent le responsable du
secteur a pro est avec nous bonjour nous
relief jours alors ces matches de demain
sont importants le sait la deuxième
session cessèrent de la saison 2016 2017
est tout à fait en fait c'est les ils
ont un premier temps de spectacle et un
premier temps de spectacles en décembre
juste avant noël ou là en fait les
élèves de nos cours peuvent s'essayer à
l'improvisation en tout cas pour les
pour les tout nouveaux et là en fait on
est déjà dans un travail déjà plus
approfondie dans notre dans notre
démarche ou en fait voilà ils vont
pouvoir
montrer toute la mesure de
l'apprentissage qu'on peut faire dans
nos ateliers est donc là pour ces
matches trois catégories différentes
vont s'affronter alors y aura pour tous
les âges en fait ce sont les benjamins
qui sont les plus petits qui joueront
dans un premier temps ils ont entre 11 8
ans et 11 ans puis enchaîneront les
cadets de trappes donc la pole les
cadets ils ont entre 12 et 15
et ensuite ce sont les juniors qui eux
ont entre 15 et 19 ans et pour eux voilà
ils accueilleront l'équipe de boulogne
billancourt
voilà ça va être un petit peu le match
phare de la journée est donc là
qu'importe les agents vous la vie ça va
de 8 ans à la 17 ans a à peu près un
petit peu là effectivement et donc du
coup ils sont tous plutôt à l'aise c'est
un exercice qui connaissent bien
justement le match d'improvisation
oui parce que pour le coup on a la
chance d'avoir des adhérents qui
seraient inscrites d'une année sur
l'autre du coup ils ont pour beaucoup au
moins deux ans voire pour certains 4 5
ans d'improvisation dans les baskets et
pour pour tous en fait c'est un vrai
plaisir en fait de participer à ces
matches on arriva à l'école de musique à
faire une
très bonne ambiance où les familles se
retrouvent ou voilà c'est l'occasion
comme c'est samedi un invité les cousins
et cousines et grands parents donc c'est
très a terminé rationnelle ce qui se
passe dans la salle
et puis surtout on est au soutien voilà
de deux des camarades qui sont qui
censurent le dans la patinoire
l'improvisation est alors l'impro qu'est
ce que c'est pour ceux qui connaissent
pas un petit peu à quoi en quoi ça
consiste
alors c'est un concept théâtrale qui
nous vient du canada qu'il ya du québec
par du canada francophone et
ce sont deux comédiens en fait qu'ils
ont inventé un concept autour du du
match de hockey ils ont vu les salles de
deux théâtres déserté au profit des
matchs de hockey dans les années 70 et
donc gravel et le duc ont inventé un
concept où un arbitre donne un thème à
deux équipes composées de trois garçons
et trois filles et d'un coach et du coup
à partir de ce thème là elles vont avoir
la possibilité d'improviser des
histoires qui vont durer entre 30
secondes et 20 minutes selon les textes
et à l'issue de ces de cette
improvisation là le public est invité à
voter pour l'équipe qu'il a préféré donc
ça permet de décerner des points à l'une
ou l'autre équipe à savoir qu'un certain
nombre de règles
voilà de prise de parts de construction
d'histoire à respecter
et c'est faute là aussi si elles sont
sifflés trop fréquemment et bien du coup
on peut donner des points à l'adversaire
alors un petit exemple de thématiques de
tête qu'est-ce que j'ai fait récemment
le
la légende des chardons afghans alors on
a fait d'accord à part de la clio parce
que faut savoir que pour le coup cette
histoire là l'histoire donne au chardon
afghan a donné l'histoire de deux fleurs
qui voulait quitter leur pays pour aller
trouver une terre meilleur et pour
voiles à ne plus qu'on les traite de
piquant mais de fleurs au belcenter tout
ça donc 2006 elle a des belles histoires
jeu par des enfants donc vous voyez il
ya pas mal de choses et pas mal de
choses qu'on le thème n'est qu'un
prétexte pour pour l'improvisation à
partir de là c'est comme dans le cinéma
le thème peut parler exactement du fin
le titre du film parle exactement du
titre de l'histoire mais en même temps
il peut y avoir une forme de métaphore
pour raconter plein d'autres choses cet
événement de demain c'est un peu une
mise en jambe pour le mondial d'impro
qui se déroule du 13 au 16 avril
exactement ça va être un petit peu
l'inde est l'un des événements phares
parce qu'il y en a d'autres cette année
à déclic mais en tout cas c'est le
mondial d'improvisation junior qui s'est
jouée qui se joue pour la troisième
année
donc cette année à trappes c'est à
l'initiative d'un collectif qu'on a
formé voilà avec une compagnie qui
s'appelle un procès à au québec
l'aef pays à de bruxelles et
la ligue d'impro junior de suisse et
l'idée c'était de monter un championnat
d'improvisation mondiale est régulier et
du coup voilà ça se partage entre
on accueille à notre tour voilà le
mondial cette année et c'est alors
qu'ils allaient vous accueillir jusqu
alors sont les équipes donc on accueille
ces trois équipes peuvent donc je viens
de citer la compagnie impro sierra la
compagnie la ligue d'improvisation
suisse d'improvisation juniors suisses
et live biya de bruxelles et donc on les
accueille sur l'île de loisirs à saint
quentin en yvelines
ça c'est pour l'hébergement les accueils
attrape surtout et pour nous c'est très
important de les accueillir à trappes
parce que on veut montrer aussi voilà
tous les aspects culturels de notre
ville et on sait que l'improvisation et
il ya une place importante sur notre
territoire et et puis voilà c'est une
manière aussi de parler de notre ville
sans passer par le prisme des médias
sans vouloir juger téléfilm est un
travail merveilleux
cependant voilà en annoncé on connaît
voilà on connaît la réputation de nos
deals et pour y vivre au quotidien on a
envie que montrer autre chose
voilà ce qu'ont les belges c'est rigolo
parce que pour certains belges ils
viennent de molenbeek et on peut
connaître tous les effets tous les échos
qui a eu sans faire de sans faire de
politique sans faire de voilà tout va
bien tout à fait on attendait accueillir
à son cap ja et puis bah un bel
événement à suivre c'est du 13 au 16
avril et les matches d'impro les
premiers c'est demain à suivre du coup à
l'école de musique et de danse de
trappes
merci beaucoup nous rallier kind est
revenu sur notre plateau voilà on peut
voir la petite le petit flyer surtout
les mondiaux de l'impro à ne pas manquer
et tous les rendez-vous et informations
sur la compagnie sont à retrouver sur le
site internet merci encore nous rallier
merci beaucoup et on va parler
exposition à présent jusqu'au 2 avril
voisins le bretonneux rassemble les
artistes lauréats des deux dernière
biennale de peinture et de sculpture des
bateaux envoie des animaux en métal tout
un univers à découvrir à l'espace de
coville petit tour d'horizon sur les
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
encre pastel métal ou bois ici les
matériaux se rencontrent et se répondent
des créatures rouillé fantaisiste de
ghislain de l'usso aux formes sensuelles
sculpté par frédéric marquis des
personnages féminins qui se tordent et
se retourne pour occuper l'espace
c'est vraiment une histoire de
mouvements de silhouettes en mouvement
mais comment une silhouette qui
apparemment est justin une une image va
être modelé et va être va prendre
l'espace et va au contraire donner une
grande impression de volume et
d'espérance voilà ça c'est l'espace et
le volume qui m'intéresse énormément
huit artistes réunis dans une même
exposition
leur point commun ils sont tous lauréats
des biennale de peinture et de sculpture
de voisins-le-bretonneux brigitte
whitechurch et professeur au centre
alfred de vigny elle dévoile à nouveau
son travail autour du papier c'est un
jeu avec la matière et avec les matières
du papier quand il est déjà tout froissé
ou quand il ya déjà des tâches ou voilà
quand il est texturé toute la trame de
vertical et d'horizontal tout le jeu de
ces lignes
ça me fascine
pas mal alors j'ai fait toute une série
là dessus avec les papiers
le visiteur plonge dans un univers
urbain des étals colorés
une découverte de toute la richesse
artistique de notre territoire et c'est
maintenant la maman de notre rendez-vous
juniors vous manquez d'idées sorties
pour les plus jeunes pas de panique mais
ni poker est là pour nous aider mais
c'est plutôt elle qui venait petit souci
le micro c'est pas grave on arrivera
quand même à faire la chronique il n'y a
aucun souci mélanie et vous avez préparé
trois idées pour ce week end une pour se
dépenser une pour vibrer et la troisième
pour s'évader et quatrième on se marrait
c'est ici vous voudrez de démarrer la
chronique pour savourer résumé camille
et je trouve tout de suite on commence
par le rendez vous pour se dépenser et
si vous jeter à l'eau alors les 12
heures de natation de crabes sont de
retour de 9h à 21h la piscine à
jacqueline coup de la commune lance un
défi pour les enfants qui ne savent pas
nager
brassart autorisés s'ils sont
accompagnés de la famille mais autrement
on n'a pas le droit d'équipé de matériel
donc c'est une
c'est un challenge et une manifestation
sportive qui a adressé plutôt un public
de nageurs on essaie de sensibiliser les
gens aussi alors à la pratique de ce
sport en famille ou individuelle alors
12 heures de natation ça semble long
quand même un tout le monde peut y
participer mais oui parce qu'en fait il
ya plusieurs challenge à relever lors
des relais en famille dès challenge
individuel ou collectif un record de
l'heure ou juste des traversées il ya
une obligation
savoir nager au moins 50 mètres son
matériel
c'est à dire faire un aller-retour donc
les poissons de tout âge sont attendus
il y a deux ans près de 250 personnes
étaient revenus étaient venus par non
relever ce défi et vous avez un deuxième
rendez vous sportif mais plutôt en tant
que spectateur cette fois et oui et
celui-là c'est celui pour vibrer il a
lieu au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et c'est du
handball les joueuses d'ici paris en
convoi à l'image affronte brest bretagne
c'est l'occasion de voir des choses
international il y à un record à battre
celui des spectateurs plus de saintes
cinq mille personnes sont attendues et
le coup d'envoi est donné à 18 heures ça
ne
25 mars et on change totalement
d'univers avec maurepas qui nous propose
de redécouvrir l'histoire du petit
chaperon rouge
ben oui y'a pas que du sport ce week-end
quand même il ya aussi de la culture et
c'est petit rouge le nom du spectacle
pas besoin je pense qu'amy de vous
rappeler l'histoire du petit chaperon
rouge on la connaît tous
mais la particularité de ce spectacle
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de texte
tout est visuel avec un jeu de
marionnettes et de lumière c'est une
petite bulle poétique que l'on peut voir
dès l'âge de 4 ans histoire de se donner
envie on regarde l'extrait du moratoire
une fois dans la forêt non il fait avec
noir ah ben moi je vais y aller dans la
forêt pour porter du gâteau à grand mère
après
[Musique]
et merci mélanie ne nous avoir parlé de
ces différents rendez vous avec tout ça
les enfants ne risquent pas de s'ennuyer
ce week end c'est la fin de ce set 8
loisirs merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
je vous retrouve vendredi propres au
prochain pardon pour un nouveau numéro
je vous souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]